So it's not a secret that not every 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate is all in for Medicare
for all or
even for similar sort of universal coverage
proposals.
And one of those people is Joe Biden.
Joe Biden has now said more about the specifics
of his healthcare proposal.
And it's so outrageous that more than half
of Americans straight up can't afford it.
And what I mean by that is Joe Biden was interviewed
on who TV the other day.
As many of you know, local news stations are
crazy about copyright.
So I'm not going to play any clips for you,
but you can easily find the interview online
and check it out in full.
And in this interview with the TV station,
Joe Biden says that his approach is not a
Bernie Sanders ask Medicare for all approach,
which we knew it's building on Obamacare.
And Biden specifically says that he wants
to further subsidize private insurance, which
is completely broken, of course, in order
to reduce yearly copays to $1,000.
So for context, a lot of the plans that Biden
is talking about have $2,000 a year of copays
or a, I'm sorry, uh, deductibles.
I said, I think I said a copay, but I mean
deductible.
He wants to reduce to $1,000 deductible plans
that right now might have a $2,000 deductible
or a $2,500 deductible.
And he's also open to a public option.
And the primary problem with all of this is
that it's completely unaffordable for hundreds
of millions of people and it doesn't actually
address the real issues with our healthcare
system.
And I'll explain to you both of those points.
You might remember that a few months ago we
did a story about a study which found that
presented with an unexpected $400 emergency
expense, 40% of the country can't afford it.
And by can't afford it, it means they either
would have to take out a loan or go into debt,
charge it, uh, and pay it off at interest
or borrow from family or get a payday loan.
Imagine, which is the worst opportunity, a
possibility in order to cover the unexpected
$400 expense.
Joe Biden is saying, I will further subsidize
insurance in order to reduce the yearly deductible
from whatever it is, 2,500 to 32,000 sometimes
even more down to $1,000 out of pocket Max
if 40% can't afford an unexpected $400 expense,
and then certainly more than half of the country
can't afford $1,000 deductible above and beyond
premiums and medications and so on and so.
Now what this also ignores of course is the
cost of the plans themselves.
Biden's talking just about lowering the deductible
to $1,000 and then Biden ads, I guess sort
of like as a wink wink or an attempt to bring
in some of the people who understand how broken
our healthcare system is.
Biden says that he's also open to a public
option and sure, a public option is a fine
idea if you are comparing between what we
have now and what we have now plus a public
option.
Sure, I'll take the public auction option,
but a congressional budget office study found
that a public option would basically only
lower monthly premiums by seven to 8%.
This barely makes a dent, especially when
you consider how quickly premiums are going
up year after year.
Biden also repeats in this interview, what
is basically a Republican talking point, which
is that under Bernie Sanders, medicare for
all plan, you would lose your insurance.
It's incredibly dishonest.
It's not true.
The way it would work is a public option would
be put in place immediately during the four
year phase in to Medicare for all during which
the uh, age for Medicare eligibility gets
lowered and lowered until everybody is in
to say you lose your insurance under Bernie's
plan is incomplete at best and completely
dishonest and a Republican talking point at
worse.
Th th this is the worst part of Joe Biden.
These are Republican for profit health insurance
company talking points and Joe Biden is repeating
them.
Now I will, you know, try to find some kind
of silver lining here.
The one thing I appreciate about Joe Biden
is he's being upfront with us.
He's not for Medicare for all and he's telling
us he's not for Medicare for all.
We can debate it.
We can discuss whose plan is the best.
We can discuss whose plan would be best for
low income, middleware, whatever.
Joe Biden is not playing coy the way that
Kamala Harris did.
We're on a CNN town hall town hall.
She said Medicare for all is the way and then
the next day put out a statement saying Medicare
for all would be one way and tweaking Obamacare
is another way that I would also be open to
Joe Biden has been upfront.
He's not for Medicare for all.
He's been up front with the wealthy donors
behind closed doors, but it went public saying
you're privileged status will remain on changed
if I become president of the United States.
He is safe for the super rich.
He's been upfront.
I don't agree with Biden's politics.
I think it's terrible, but he is not sugarcoating
it to appear more progressive than he is and
we can actually evaluate it for what it actually
is rather than having to read between the
lines and what my assessment is.
Is that it's horrible and I completely disagree
with it.